The Joe Rogan experience.
Do you know the Hylo came,
uh,
not enough to really play it,
but,
um,
I spent a little bit of time pick him,
picking the brains of people who are good.
Yeah,
I like it.
I enjoy it.
Yeah.
I think I can,
I think I could actually get pretty good at it.
It's like the basics of it seems pretty simple.
It's just a matter of like getting comfortable there because I feel like my
knees are just,
I don't want to risk it,
you know what I mean?
Oh,
let's play this game a little bit.
Yeah.
But if I find a partner that's not an asshole,
just like really wants to like learn together or whatever,
then I'll,
I'll do it.
I'll go after it.
Do you ever see yourself doing Jujitsu matches or anything like that?
Yeah,
I've only done maybe three of my life.
Yeah.
I did one my last year as competition was probably two years ago,
two and a half years ago.
Naga,
just like,
it was a random,
just like a random like,
oh,
okay,
I'll do not go today.
Well,
there are some MMA fighters that are at a high enough level of grappling that
they can compete against really elite grapplers and Jiu Jitsu matches,
you know,
like,
um,
Chad Mendez member,
he had that,
um,
that match with,
Jeff,
fuck,
why am I blanking on his name?
Not Jeff Glover.
Jeff Glover.
Really?
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
I think he choked him out.
And thank you.
Chad Mendez choked out.
Yeah.
Jeff Glover,
I think he took his back and tapped him.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
I think they were using the Eddie Bravo,
uh,
invitational rules.
Makes,
make sure that's true.
Ah,
which you start on someone's back.
Yeah.
You know,
and over time you go to a certain distance.
Is that Chael Sonnen Schmidt is,
it's chill Sonance organization,
in which case,
I'm pretty sure they use a,
the Ebi rules.
So he got his back through sort of on one of those over time positions,
but he still tapped him.
And the other one is Uriah faber.
Uriah favors pretty fucking elite.
Pretty fucking elite like Jen Glover's animal.
Oh my God,
I love that guy.
Super,
super technical.
You know?
And very dangerous and relaxed.
Right.
Big Time stoner.
Yeah.
So they must have set him up on his back.
This doesn't show it.
It just shows them how the back man,
that's a hell of a fucking ruined egg.
And right there that works all day on everybody.
Even a Jeff Glover.
Wow.
That's why Jiu Jitsu works,
you know,
it'll,
if you're a lead it'll work.
Save your ass.
Yeah.
Three by overtime submission.
So we were correct.
Yeah.
There's this,
so there's a few guys,
but it's really hard to be the master of everything.
Right?
Yeah,
for sure.
So for you,
is there a balance where you're like,
am I spending enough time grappling?
Am I spending enough time striking?
Do you,
do you ever like wonder what the correct formula is or do you with it at all?
I have wondered and I always wonder,
but
I can't like so a long time ago,
maybe like a few years ago,
Anderson told me like,
listen,
just you need Jujitsu.
Like you need it.
He's like,
it saved my life.
I love to strike too.
But when I learned Jujitsu,
it changed my life.
So you need to learn it.
Put on a g,
let's roll.
Like you're right there in the living room,
you know?
And I was just like,
okay.
So one of the things that I learned from him is just,
he's like,
learn the basic stuff,
like learn the basic stuff,
get really good at it,
and then,
and then like use it to save yourself and you'll,
you'll end up growing.
He's like,
just keep training Jujitsu.
You don't need this whole crazy secret system at the moment.
Just make sure that you're training Jujitsu and continue to learn Jujitsu.
You know,
like,
so that's kind of my takeaway from the conversation.
So I just make sure that when I'm training,
at least I'm doing Jujitsu,
you know,
like I focus on it,
make sure that I'm getting better,
make sure that I'm going with guys that are way better than me.
So I'm always getting my ass kicked by.
At least I'm always going with guys that are better than me all the time.
Um,
and like I enjoy it,
but I'm a striker.
That's it.
Like I enjoy it,
I know that I need it.
It's my job.
I know that it can get dangerous if I go against,
you know,
if I go against the guy was a high level Jujitsu.
I know that,
I understand that and I'm very aware of it every time that I trained and I,
so I make sure that I do my job and I go to Jujitsu class,
but I'm a striker and I'm always going to be focused on,
that's always going to be what?
Like my Goto,
anybody,
whether it's a strike or a grappler,
I don't care.
I'm going to train striking and I'm going to train Jujitsu too,
but I'm going into my striking always.
Do you think that that is like you letting everybody know,
are you trying to trick people and then next,
next fight you're going to shoot on folks.
Oh,
I don't need the shoe.
I'll shoot if I need to.
Like if I'm getting my ass kicked in,
I need to take a desperation shot.
But you would rather just let them know that you're coming out striking because
one of the things that I believe you do and you're very good at it,
but one of the things that's interesting about real high level MMA,
when you look at the guys who were bent,
who've been like legendarily successful like George Saint Pierre or mighty
mouse,
two great examples.
One of the things is you never knew what the fuck they're going to do to you and
that overloading the mind with possibilities is a part of their success.
It's like how much of a part,
it's a good question.
Do you think that there's an argument for using the skills that you have which
are quite spectacular with that sort of style sort of style that incorporates
way more take downs,
way more take down attempts way more just just different combinations of things.
So you never know what the fuck is happening at any given time or do you think
that it's better to just be the best striker you can and that'll be enough?
You stop those take downs.
That'll be enough for me.
For you or just in general?
For you,
for you?
I think for me it would be the best to just
be the best striker because you enjoy it that much more.
I enjoy it that much more.
Um,
you know,
I think,
yeah,
I enjoy that much more.
I still have a lot to learn,
a lot to grow so that it's always going to get better.
I don't think that it's,
yeah,
I don't think that's going to get bad.
I'm still learning a lot.
Especially what you guys got to see like a few weeks ago.
Right.
That's only the beginning.
Like everything,
even before that was like
nonexistent compared to like the type of training that I've been doing.
So I'm like,
I'm really excited.
ah,
boy ties a lot more than just punch kicks and elbows,
you know?
And that's,
that's all the striking.
It's a mind game.
It's infatuated by it right now.
Yeah.
You just want to focus on 100%.
Like there's guys like,
uh,
think about like Michael Vinton page,
right?
Like before he fought like Paul Daley,
I'm sure that guy trains a lot of grappling as well.
And it shows like if he gets in positions,
like he's knocked out guys from weird,
weird positions,
but when people watch him fight,
they want to see like they trust in his stand up.
They're like,
oh,
this guy's going to do some crazy stuff.
Yeah.
And I kind of want to be able to do the same thing.
Not Crazy,
like,
you know,
worldly stuff.
But when people watch me fight,
they know what to expect.
And that's just like bulletproof striking.